i can confirm that there's been a
a barbaric terrorist attack
what looks like a series of attacks in
kabul on the airport of the crowds at
the airport in which
members of the u.s military very sadly
have lost their lives and many afghan
casualties as well and we extend our
condolences
both to the united states of america and
to the people
of afghanistan
and i look i want to stress that
this threat of a terrorist attack
is
one of the constraints that we've been
operating under in uh
operation pitting in the the big
extraction that's been
that's been going on and uh
we've been ready for it we've been
prepared for it
and i want to stress that
we're
going to continue uh with that operation
and we're now coming to
towards the the end of it to the very
end of it
in any event and
we've already
extracted uh the overwhelming majority
of of those
uh under under both the schemes the the
eligible persons the uk persons uk
nationals plus the uh the afghans the
interpreters
and others and it's been a totally
phenomenal effort by the uk there's been
nothing like it uh for decades and and
decades um but clearly what this attack
shows is the importance of uh continuing
that work in as fast and as efficient a
manner as possible in the hours that
remain to us and that's what we're going
to do
prime minister has today's attack made
any difference at all to the timeline
for the evacuation ben wallace said
yesterday that there were still 1500
afghan resettlement eligibilities
people who are eligible for that scheme
waiting to come out
how will progress feel for them on the
ground
well i've just shared a cobra and uh the
conclusion is that we're able to
continue with the programming in the way
that we uh we've been running it
according to the the the timetable that
uh that we've got and that's what we're
going to do because
uh
the overwhelming majority of those who
are eligible have now been uh extracted
from
afghanistan and we're gonna we'll work
flat out the uh the military the the
foreign office teams the the home office
in border force teams are there uh
getting people through as as fast as
they can still
and uh we're gonna keep going up until
uh the last moment but i wanna i want to
repeat what i've been saying over the
last few days
that
we also fully expect that those who want
to leave afghanistan
after this phase one if you like are
allowed to do that by the taliban and we
will use all the influence that we can
bring to bear with a political or
economic uh diplomatic
as as we said at the g7
to encourage the new authorities in
in afghanistan to do that
by creating this evacuation you
encourage
hundreds thousands of afghans to be on
the perimeter of the airport almost
sitting ducks it feels like aren't you
worried that we could be in a situation
where there's a second attack and that
more people could lose their lives
this is something sound that we've
prepared for for for a very long time
and
going to to see the uh the command
headquarters at uh to uh this morning uh
you really
understood that the military have uh our
military uk military have been preparing
for this evacuation for months uh and
months and
um
uh what we're now coming to is the final
phases the final stages of that uh
evacuation we always knew that this was
a moment where uh of course there were
going to be particular vulnerabilities
to to terrorism to opportunistic
terrorist attacks uh we condemn them uh
i think they're despicable uh but i'm
afraid that uh
there's something that we've had to
prepare for it isn't going to
interrupt our progress we're going to
get on with this
evacuation and i just remind you you
know since august the 14th this country
has evacuated uh from afghanistan the uk
military has evacuated the equivalent of
a you know a town uh the size of uh i
don't know is it dawking or petersfield
a a largish uk town and uh that is a
phenomenal achievement now what we've
got to do we're going to make sure is
that we continue to
vet the people who are coming through
check them
and ensure that they're able to
contribute to uk society when they come
i'm sure they will be able to do that
finally what did you make of the taliban
statement condemning the attacks and
what is your intelligence of who was
behind them
i don't want to comment on uh
intelligence uh matters but i think what
it
possibly one one thing one thing we
could say is this that
there were
almost certainly members of the taliban
who were themselves killed uh in this
attack and perhaps what it proves is the
difficulty that any
government is going to have in in
running afghanistan and the threats that
any government is going to continue
to face and
what we want to do right now
is to is to get on uh with this finish
off this process of evacuation but then
move into the the second phase uh where
clearly that we want to work with other
partner countries uh
in the g7 and others in nato and others
uh to engage with the the taliban to try
to get a political process going that
gives a a more inclusive future an
inclusive and representative
for afghanistan and one that commands
the the loyalty and support of the
people of afghanistan because you can
see from this attack that that is not
going to be easy